so I have a question is Quito too hard
is it too restrictive in this video
we're just gonna make it a lot easier
for someone new starting on a healthy
keto plan okay number one let's talk
about craving carbohydrates now I don't
expect anyone to do this program
with cravings that's impossible that's
torture okay one thing that happens when
you start this program is your cravings
will go away completely so that's gonna
make it really easy to do this okay plus
realize that you can do substitute foods
for just about any of the desserts or
junk food that you like okay and I'll
put a link down below with a lot of good
ideas so we're gonna have to get rid of
the cravings to make it easy to do okay
number two you might be too hungry and
that's difficult because you're
constantly hungry your blood sugar
issues whatever the way to solve that is
to add fat to the meals that's the most
satisfying and it's the thing that's
gonna not trigger insulin too much so
nuts
avocado there's a lot of different
things you can add to the meal
I think nut butters are great almond
almond butter so that would actually
make it a lot easier number three you
might love the starches okay potato rice
bread and that makes it really hard to
do this program
that's true but there are certain foods
that will act as a substitute foods that
will greatly help you and one is our
favorite cauliflower and I know you've
probably already tried this a million
times but you could turn cauliflower
into almost about mac and cheese
cauliflower into an amazing pizza I mean
I have some recipes I'll put down below
picture this cook cauliflower bacon
cream and cheese okay if that's not
comfort food I don't know what is it's
actually very very delicious so you can
do some similar things that are kind of
starch like number four you don't like
vegetables and this is making it very
difficult now why don't you start on a
gradient and just do a small amount of
vegetables even if you do pickles or
even sauerkraut it's a start
something is better than nothing
okay if you just can do one small salad
then start with that the salad acts as a
fiber to feed the microbes the salad
gives you nutrients in minerals that's
why we want a certain amount of
vegetables but again start with a
smaller amount number five plan out your
day
don't go meal to meal you're gonna be
thrown off so for someone recently I
made it really super simple I said just
do two meals and for your lunch do four
eggs bacon and nuts okay just as much as
you want till you're satisfied and then
for dinner do a salad chicken with nut
butter just made it super simple don't
snack just do that and they said oh I
can do that that's pretty simple so you
want to plan out the day so you have a
plan that's kind of like the hidden step
before you do a program is understanding
like okay what you're gonna be having to
prepare and what environment have to be
in to get the food because a lot of
times if you're going for meal the meal
it's like you're gonna be thrown off
number six instead of starting with keto
keep your current diet in your meals
just start with in a minute fasting as a
way to enter this okay enter into this
program why is this gonna help you
because if you eat less frequent you'll
drop insulin and that is going to make
it a lot easier to do this and it's also
going to make you feel better so start
with just in a minute fasting so just do
two meals or even one meal and then eat
whatever you want okay as a way to kind
of start this program seven get all your
junk food out of your house you don't
want to have it they're tempting
yourself you don't want it out on the
counters anything that you shouldn't be
eating should not be in the house to
make it easier and less tempting okay
number eight hire a food service to
deliver your keto meals
okay there's plenty of services around
find one and have them prepared for you
I mean it's a little more expensive but
again this will make it a little bit
easier okay number nine start with the
most important thing as a starting point
which is cutting out the snacks okay
that's the killer just by cutting out
the snacks you'll see a huge change with
a lot of different health health things
so we want to add more fat to the meal
to prevent the need for a snack so this
means no snack between lunch and dinner
and no grazing at night okay I think if
you can apply any one of these it'll
make it a little bit easier thanks for
watching
hey so if you haven't done so please
press subscribe now that way you can be
aware of all the new content that I'm
putting out on a regular basis